eu ainda me lembro muito bem da sensação
de me sentir perdido de não viver a vida
que eu realmente queria viver que não
ser a pessoa que eu realmente queria ser
eu pensava demais e fazia de - eu
sonhava demais e vivia de menos
foi quando decidi largar um emprego como
programador de software encararmos medo
de me tornar músico uma revolução
aconteceu em minha vida
muito prazer a todos que grande honra
poder compartilhar com vocês meu nome é
felipe burgo novo eu acho que eu posso
começar essa história falando que eu sou
uma pessoa muito intensa seja minhas
emoções
meus pensamentos ou nas coisas que eu
faço eu tenho uma extrema necessidade de
me sentir vivo de sentir o coração
batendo mais forte de vento intensamente
a música passou a ter um grande
significado na minha vida há alguns anos
atrás quando terminei um relacionamento
e eu estava sentindo emoções muito
fortes dentro de mim e eu precisava
analisar aquilo de alguma forma colocar
pra fora
só que quando abre a boca pra falar as
palavras simplesmente não chegavam perto
de dizer aquilo que eu queria dizer
elas eram pequenas demais e aí eu tocava
meu violão e para esse crime entendia a
música me entendia eu finalmente
conseguiu colocar pra fora
nesta época trabalhava como programador
software
eu me via horas por dia na frente de um
computador é o meu lado tinha uma janela
minha esquerda bem grande e olhava pra
fora viu verde vivo das árvores viu céu
azul claro e vilson brilhante de alguma
forma que me chamava que une a traía e
aí olhava o código-fonte olhava para
aquela janela gráfica defanti olhar para
aquela janela
naquele momento ainda não tinha
entendido só que aquela janela era muito
mais do que uma janela aquela janela
representava a minha vida minha vida
estava lá fora acontecendo os meus
sonhos estavam lá enquanto estava ali
sentado numa cadeira resolvendo erros de
um sistema que de nada tinha a ver
comigo
minha mãe é aquela mulher maravilhosa
ela sempre me dizia que o sonho da vida
dela ter sido dentista só que ela não
foi porque ela tinha 8
vamos pra cuidar ela me dizia também
muitas vezes que eu tinha que comer pão
um banho porque não tinha outra coisa
pra comer
então como eu que tive a oportunidade de
vida que tive acesso à educação graças
ao trabalho árduo dos meus pais
vou jogar isso tudo fora para quando
tiver 40 50 anos e olhar pro meu filho
fala filho meu sonho era ter sido músico
só que eu não fui por medo por falta de
coragem porque eu não tem oito irmãos
para cuidar eu tenho uma irmã sou mais
velha ela que cuida de mim eu não posso
usar se desculpe não quer usar a
desculpa alguma na verdade eu tinha
muitos medos muitos não sei os dentro de
mim
em um desses medos feras justamente
largar essa segurança financeira esse
caminho mais fácil mais confortável pra
me arriscar no mundo da música
só que ao mesmo tempo tinha certeza eu
sentia que a música me aproximava de mim
enquanto o programa são só me afastava
e aí existe esses dois mundos o mundo
falava que tinha cursar uma faculdade
para ter um bom emprego comprar um bom
carro e uma boa casa e tinha o mundo do
menino sonhador que não nega essas
coisas só que ele é mais ele tem um
sentido para viver
ele quer provar pra ele mesmo que é
capaz de se vencer e de conquistar os
seus sonhos
duas pessoas representar esses mundos
por um lado minha mãe representava muita
emoção intuição fé perseverança
sentimento e logo de cara quando o
contexto do que ela já me deu muita
força muito apoio e quando fui falar com
o meu pai foi um pouco diferente porque
até então tinha essa imagem dele como
uma pessoa é racional pé no chão na
palavra eu devido às dificuldades de sua
vida agora que estão começando a
entender isso pai
respeito muito ele não se dá ao luxo de
acreditar em sonhos bobos e aí ele me
falou filho tem certeza que é isso
fresh eu tenho vários amigos músicos eu
acompanhei a vida deles eu sei que não é
nada fácil realmente tem certeza
e eu falei é pai cada dia que passa
estou ficando mais triste naquele
emprego simplesmente precisa sair de lá
preciso atrás de mim
então tá e assim com o apoio dos meus
pais conquistado eu larguei meu emprego
com um programador soft e comecei a
estudar música em período integral e aí
eu pensei se eu realmente vou fazer isso
meus pais que já trabalharam a vida
inteira vamos continuar trabalhando para
instalar naquela casa estudando vou
fazer cada segundo vale a pena vou me
levar o máximo do meu pai
inicial e assim o fiz eu comecei a
estudar de domingo a domingo de manhã e
de tarde de noite muito com serra muito
focado
visualizando projetando aquilo que o
click e consequentemente atraindo depois
de um mês me convidaram pra assistir o
ensaio da camerata de violões clássicos
da universidade de blumenau
eu fui o que entendeu que era essa tal
de câmera ata e logo que entrei pela
sala já fiquei encantado fascinado com
aquilo quatro violões um dialogando com
o outro de forma muito harmônica o
violão um ano só os agudos bilhão e
cantando como uma luz do sol radiante
estridente
já o vilão 4 nos baixos graves era como
chão com uma terra para esse sol brilhar
eo violão 2 e 3 que preencheu os espaços
restantes como a natureza que sempre
busca pelo equilíbrio
naquele momento eu só pensava o quanto
eu queria ser um daqueles vilões e
quanto queria estar ali entre eles chega
em casa
focado decidido falei eu vou integrar a
camerata de violões custe o que custar
vou me dedicar e vai dar certo e aí
comecei a me dedicar mais ainda dia após
dia semana após semana até que depois de
mais ou menos um mês no professor vendo
esse meu desenvolver esse meu processo
finalmente mexer me chamou para fazer
parte da camerata eu comecei a tocar
entre eles
eu fiquei muito feliz com isso porque
pela primeira vez na minha vida estava
me sentindo eu de verdade pela primeira
vez eu estava correndo atrás daquilo que
fazia meu coração bater mais forte
e desculpa e para cada desafio que ia
vencendo eu ia me tornando mais forte de
forma que eu pensava e agora com o
desafio que vou vencer qual destaco que
eu fiz vou esperar e dessa forma foi
desenvolvendo uma força interior muito
grande
até que depois de alguns meses ver o meu
novo grande desafio que foi meu primeiro
show autoral eu estava desenvolvendo
essas músicas paralelamente com os
estudos da câmera ata e esse jogo foi
importante para mim porque eu gosto
muito de pensar que eu não faço músicas
que não sou o dono das músicas não crio
as músicas eu sou música
elas são parte de mim parte de quem eu
sou então através das minhas músicas eu
poderia me abrir as pessoas e mostrar
toda essa revolução de idéias de busca
por novos valores de uma nova forma de
viver que eu estava ali vivenciando e
mais bacana desse show que as pessoas
não ficaram nem simplesmente sentadas
aplaudido no final de cada música eu
abrir o olho levantava a cabeça parece
que tá
todo mundo tocando comigo assim era uma
energia muito incrível as pessoas
emocionadas aplaudido com muito
entusiasmo e no final do show muitas
pessoas vieram agradecer e cumprimentar
e sinceramente uma das sensações mais
incríveis que já senti na minha vida uma
pessoa emocionada parar um instante de
olhar no olho e agradecer por aquele
momento que proporcionou a ela
só que eu só me dei conta de verdade do
poder do potencial que agora tinha em
mãos quando uma amiga minha veio me
falar que o meu pai é aquela pessoa que
até então eu vinha com uma pessoa rita
dura e que hoje na verdade o ciclista um
coração gigantesco dentro dele
ela me falou que meu pai não parava de
chorar o seu trabalho e eu fiquei muito
feliz com isso meu conseguir
proporcionar esse até pro meu pai claro
que coisa linda isso e a partir daí eu
coloquei na minha cabeça que eu queria
que minha vida fosse assim porque tu
poder proporcionar um momento bom para
alguém momento de emoção ou simplesmente
tirar um sorriso da cara de alguém e um
mundo de onde as pessoas geralmente são
grosseiras com as outras e se machucam
diariamente é muito linda diz um grande
amigo meu chamado rubens no último show
ele me falou o seguinte felipe
a arte não é apenas um espelho que
reflete mundo mas sim um martelo de
forja então através da música via
possibilidade de forjar o mundo que eu
acredito é melhor porque tudo que eu sou
hoje no 1 fui sozinho não conquistei
sozinho muitas pessoas queridas
iluminados me ajudar a me tornar essa
pessoa desde amigos e famílias e família
a outros músicos que ouvia as músicas
deles e de alguma forma estavam ali
dialogando comigo me inspirando me
ajudando me vencer
eu demorei um pouco de tempo para
entender a concepção da maioria das
pessoas de música como entretenimento
porque é pra mim a música sempre foi um
momento de interiorização de de reflexão
e até mesmo de meditação onde através
daquele momento que a música me
proporcionava eu sentia paz necessária
para encontrar as minhas respostas eu
realmente conseguia ver se eu estava
sendo que eu queria ser e realmente me
encaminhando para a vida que eu queria
ter porque eu gosto muito de pensar que
a nossa vida uma história de filme teste
que já tem
assim quem está com a caneta eo papel
nas mãos somos nós
nós escrevemos a nossa própria história
então cabe a nós mesmos fazer os nossos
sonhos acontecer e correr atrás de
realmente quem a gente quer ser
eu vou tocar a última música agora que
se chama cada instante eu espero
justamente com essa música proporcionar
um momento de reflexão para vocês porque
muitas vezes a gente fica procurando
muita referência externa o mundo vive
nos bombardeando com muita informação
tem que fazer isso tem que fazer aqui
aquilo onde na verdade a gente só
precisa se interiorizar um pouquinho e
nos perguntar o que a gente quer que o
nosso coração quer
i
d
min